[Music]
which kid wants to be in show business
uh he's the youngest it's cliche you
know she wants to be like a dad yeah we
uh we discovered it um
my wife is right around the emmys uh
i was nominated yes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i didn't get the golden globe i didn't
no no those are it's all right so it's
good to put in perspective here's the
deal with the golden globes it's like 75
80 foreign journalists make up the
hollywood foreign press yeah i've slept
with three of them
so when i didn't get the nomination the
real the real question that puzzled me
was is that
it was it was it not enough or
was it too many
[Laughter]
anyway i'm going to go with not enough i
think sleeping with 3 out of 80 not
enough yeah i i'd like to think so i
don't know we're not on speaking terms
the three but anyway uh uh my wife's
putting on uh getting dressed and
putting on her makeup and the youngest
is in the mirror practicing
her emmy acceptance speech
honestly just uh she's got makeup on how
old are we talking here eight she's
eight years old and she's got she's
putting she's doing an emmy acceptance
speech in the mirror
listen i know i'm an amazing actress
but please don't don't give it to me
give it to my father
he's worked so
hard my father the best actress emmy
you know what they say there are no
actors only actresses
but
i'll be honest it's better than the
speech i had planned so i was impressed
really did you have a speech planned i
know you i i did yeah yeah i thought
it'd be good to be prepared yeah and
look i uh kyle chandler won the emmy it
was a lovely i was very happy for him um
i feel like he deprived some people of a
good speech um
you think you you think you had the
better emmy speech
a little insight my opening line uh
this was my wife's idea actually uh i
was going to look at the uh it's a
trophy of some kind and uh and then and
then look out at my wife of 20 years and
say
well honey this is it
i'm finally leaving you
[Music]
that would have killed that's just the
ultimate great and then it goes from
there from there i mean i had i had
i don't know i know they play music but
i had five minutes